I'm going to help you work through these
because they're also they get as as you
can see I'm pretty happy with the
answers that you can see there just
quickly had it I owned and I confirmed
that we knew what's going on up the top
it's not really much that happens is
their G squared versus G so this one's
going to go you lose that one not the
really happen to the threads of bought
no common factors so the three of the
footage they put we want to hear what do
we lose piggy from the top of the button
and then here today there and so you
have one egg two Q's make you sweat you
can see by the way just wear again to
the next one
I am trying to cancel first and then I
put things together I could have put
everything together and had a new
numerator put everything together having
in denominator and then cancel but
you're kind of doing all this extra work
yeah when you can just get rid of things
get rid of them first and then combine
what's left okay a muscle that's already
been solved you need to take this guy
and all the stuff that we've just showed
about canceling really works when we're
dealing with multiplication the product
but right we don't have that here so
what do I do to turn this into a product
yeah I flip it over we actually talked
about this last time right that if
you're all like well okay so yeah when
you're dividing like you 14 divided by 2
and 2 divided by 14 they kind of
different numbers right
so unlike addition and multiplication
where you can just change the order and
do whatever you like division it does
matter so therefore it would be the same
so the line of working that would
precede this would be 9 on 10k and times
and the way we have for this by the way
I move 10 upside down because to be a
loser will take you about it is the
reciprocal right so it's 5
on six is the business I've been waiting
up this one yes sir so this one's going
so states where it's only the second one
well okay so let's come back to this
part it is let's come back to this guy
and you got division there and it works
exactly the same way I'm gonna use the
reciprocal but I'm gonna do it but if I
do like if I do this
everything's happy sorry right because
half the 14th is to 7 but if I wrote
this and do the reciprocal love poems
all right this is like someone over 28
so you're really only doing the same
thing I guess the way that this really
actually makes sense is that it's all
about this operation I thought that's
what just clipping really it's not like
I'm just gonna find any young Wizards
turn them upside down it's because the
two girls with the division what team
doesn't have an operation on it so
that's the team you chose to get off
that's why it's in tonight all right so
let's come back go back let's have a
look at the kid saying that can take
place down right let it soak in so you
can take place I bet you use a different
cups as you can see there's an M&M bad
that's easy
Nutkin seeks they both multiples all up
for you so I divide both of them by 3
that gives me 3 and 2 you can see what
that comes from yeah what other things
can I cancel in the 5 to 10 both
multiples of 5 servers so I divide both
of those is there anything that is lucky
that everything when the top is gone
except for the 3p one too
- and thank you before make sense okay
now for these lost to show you what I
prepared this is totally what it is okay
so now just for a second I'll point out
a few things here number one I say that
colors are a superpower right I wasn't
joking okay a lot of you have got the
confused
Kuja what am i pressing out when and I'm
not sure what goes with what
so it doesn't matter which colors you
saw is do you know what you're doing you
can see that I've tried to do it well
with coefficients these numbers I've
done them in red on this question right
can you see 21 + 7 21 in 7 why did I do
some canceling there because they had
toys multiples of 7 right inside divided
the night he disappeared left to be the
three same deal happens here but divided
by 5 the rest of the hat trick just goes
and this question is no harder than any
of the three that preceded it it's just
kind of longer and there's no one there
right so it's kind of there to say let
me picture in my head if you can like
wade across like a planet in front of
this we need up okay then you can do the
same thing for our really new pub that's
50 meters why this it's too much talent
right and we just take you long on it's
not more dutiful as opposed to some
question is they really deep like
they're short questions that's I don't
and you know to do in asleep know
exactly what to do
first great this my nuts off nine and
paint on n square and the same kind of
thing is happening here it's just so if
you like you didn't get to five you can
jump that on sit down you can go through
the same pants that process that I went
through and you can see why the
canceling makes us to do this first if
you do 16 times 81 you get 1296 right
which is fine it's right it's just huge
and I can't do anything with that number
whereas on once you start to cancel
things out you only get met through that
line I can take that okay so any
questions okay yeah sure look honestly
of you do whatever feels comfortable
with you all I wanted to do was make
sure I didn't confuse like for me like
there are letters the printer rolls and
there are numbers and they do behave
differently right let's see that too
that's not like a to out the front of a
number that means there's P times P it
means something different so that's why
in this case do with that one I just ran
out of colors power in this case I left
red for the coefficients for numbers and
green for predators for letters but the
important thing hazard most systems so
long as you have a system doesn't matter
that someone else as long as you can
make sense of it